okay welcome to this video playing
brawny Mia I am branimir and won the
last two games I played a really really
badly and i'm hoping to improve here
with this okay it starts with the fishy
opening from what okay how do you go
with air g takes the various off hmm
probably capture right hmm tricky this
is a strategically very dubious opening
for white here but he will probably
retain some some tactical chances he's
better developed yeah taking the pawn is
probably risky Bishop b5 as a move that
seems seems a bit bit of like a bit of a
problem um maybe queen bee six I can
take it form
I have no development that's really a
really problem a six seems awfully slow
okay let's do that check recheck and
castles just make sure that I get the
King out of there in the first place how
do I get developed maybe maybe queen to
be six somehow okay those checks are no
problem Bishop d3 however just this can
be easily a problem so maybe e-cigs am
to have f5 available that might be a way
to develop like f5 made Queen f6 and
then move the night okay he prevented
that one and he still has Bishop d3
probably okay i can go rook e8 9 i'd
afraid I cannot play hmm
53
well it should be three is really
difficult to meet him don't see i mean i
can't play something with f5 but that's
never going to be a really okay for me
yeah maybe I have to this kind of thing
of course why this better is a porn up
and there's no particular compensation
amazing how quickly this this went belly
up and he's got the g file open can I do
this Mary trying to trying to trade
queens here would be helpful if i can
get queens or at least he has to take I
think I'm threatening Knight c3 so might
that might be something that I can try
to defend at least okay it's giving me
the spawn back I'm lately taking it it's
clear that he has some nice squares for
the Knights but I still have two bishops
him okay but should be 69 h5 so probably
have to move that now okay I cannot go
bishop this canonical bishop is six but
his knights are trying to invade to be
six
hmm look G 897
this is very likely to end in some kind
of checkmate like Knight f6 root g7 rook
h7 don't even know how to to do anything
against that probably there is nothing
yeah Knight f6 root g7 group h seven
wins but I couldn't defend anymore this
is just too bad a position come on play
Knight df6 and win please to end my
misery here it's probably not the only
way to win but it's pretty pretty nice
okay they are probably probably there
are many ways to do it
seems he just does not see it but Knight
f6 rook to seven kills and now he sees
it I cannot even give back an exchange
or whatever its it simply simply check
made amazing
cannot even return material him well
well that must be the worst three games
in a row that I played for ages Wow it
was a terrible opening result I don't
know that this is the time this is a
type of opening it isn't really good for
what but it is tricky to play because
why it has this development and with
black it's not easy to defend with this
in this blitz blitz situation age 6 yeah
this is already may be tricky I don't
know maybe Bishop g7 I don't know yeah
after this it's it's it's impossible
almost to defend really amazing g6g form
is just immensely strong I cannot I
cannot defend h7 now it's amazing how
bad this this turns out to be and it's
it's really about this concrete concrete
thing yeah if if I get in like II six
and they're five black it's just clearly
better with two bishops we should coming
to g7 this dark squares are toast but
this is not relevant why it is clearly
better here because of this this
particular idea so maybe Bishop h6 is
really a mistake the engine wants to do
this move and then cancel TI okay this
is much safe I am if this happens now I
can go with six and possibly this I
haven't canceled yet if he goes gee for
I can play other mousse the whole thing
is that i'm always behind in development
and maybe here night to see five and
then possibly be five now this this
might be the solution yeah I'm and Here
I am lost it just lost I have no no
defense this was relatively good
relatively good and it was surprising
here ok f6 would have killed me already
he didn't see that instead he went for
the Queen trade I didn't see that as
well
check this is this is winning check and
now i'm getting killed on the G file
okay yeah here I was reasonably happy
that that I'm still in this game but
this was very strong his two nights at
to act of him they dominate my bishops
and Jim I have to go Bishop h6 it seems
yeah he already had he overlooked that
he already had this and and it's it's
all alone but I have no defense yeah f6
ok would have prolonged things but it's
just rotten he saw it and this is
probably probably this almost a forced
me TM Nigeria pg7 Luke age seven yeah he
played that nicely here I had a very bad
opening result in this game who wow what
a bad run there okay let's see maybe I
can do better in the next game thanks
for watching